est-ce que vous avez déjà réussissent à
décrocher un emploi en deux heures après
avoir déposé votre cv et bien c'est
possible aujourd'hui au centre
hospitalier de l'université montréal
donc le chum
c'est dans le cadre d'une campagne de
recrutement est clair aujourd'hui dès 8
heures donc dans les prochaines minutes
et je reçois ce matin pour en parler net
à charente hayate directrice des
ressources humaines et affaires
juridiques au chum bonjour alors on a
comparé votre campagne de recrutement du
speed dating en deux heures les gens
peuvent déjà vendre réponse après vous
avoir déposé leur cv ou jour tout à fait
donc ça fonctionne comme un os juste en
fait le candidat se présente là quand le
candidat ou la candidate en soins
infirmiers donc aujourd'hui c'est
principalement des infirmières il se
présente avec son cv on regarde de très
rapidement le cv il ya un test à passer
avec des connaissances en soins
infirmiers si le test est concluant on
passe à l'entrevue de sélection donc
c'est très rapide le tester et corrigé
immédiatement ensuite une entrevue de
sélection ont à peu près d'une durée de
30 minutes
et si c'est concluant on offre l'emploi
sous réserve évidemment du bilan médical
mais qui se fait aussi sur place dans
ces deux heures là et sous réserve de
des antécédents judiciaires de la
vérification des antécédents judiciaires
et des références qui se font quand même
ultérieure donc prenez quand même le
temps d'évaluer tout ça mais est-ce que
ça démontre à quel point c'est urgent
pour vous de combler ce poste-là ocean
en fait c'est une autre façon de
recruter on recrute toujours qu'on
continue au chum
mais les jeunes aiment ça c'est c'est
rapide c'est deux heures c'est on à la
décision immédiatement on perd moins
l'intérêt du candidat parce que souvent
le processus si on dépose le cv on
attend les boîtes vocales on convoque le
candidat donc il ya peut-être perte
d'intérêt du candidat à ce moment là
donc on essaie de faire ce très
rapidement pour captiver dont nous
ajuster aux goûts du jour vous avez
oublié dario 1 et leur façon de voir les
choses voir leur métier
quels postes sont disponibles
actuellement en fait aux chimio 250
sites d'emploi présentement ce sont des
infirmières qu'on recrute c'est une
porte ouverte pour les infirmiers
actuellement seulement ok mais on en
fait d'autres on a déjà fait d'autres
portes ouvertes pour d'autres types
d'emplois qui on continuera à le faire
alors comment ça se passe le recrutement
c'est que c'est pas facile en d'être
infirmiers infirmières par les temps qui
courent avec les heures supplémentaires
obligatoires avec les conditions de
travail conditions salariales aussi
c'est que la fille qui est en
négociations avec québec pour avoir de
meilleures conditions salariales
stationnement aussi au chum l'un qui est
fait
un exode du personnel chez vous alors
qu'est ce que vous faites pour ckoi l'a
pas comment vous faites pour pour
convaincre les gens travailler chez vous
ben en fait chez nous c'est motivant
c'est un hôpital extraordinaire on le
sait on le médiatiser beaucoup aussi
c'est un hôpital innovant avec des
technologies superbe c'est un des
meilleurs hôpitaux à mon avis les plus
technologiques non pas du tout donc
c'est très sain milieu excessivement
stimulant et pour une infirmière bien il
ya un cheminement carrière incroyable
que l'infirmière peut faire dès son
entrée jusqu'à sa retraite la ya un
cheminement de carrière un terrain peut
devenir card a pu devenir conseillère en
soins donc c'est un milieu stimulant le
réseau au complet en fait est un milieu
stimulant puis si je peux me permettre
mais les jeunes qui sont au cégep
présentement au secondaire ben il ya 250
sites d'emplois il n'y a pas que le
titre d' emploi d'infirmière le
présentement c'est celui-là qu'on
recrute mais c'est c'est magnifique mais
c'est quand même pas facile d'être
infirmiers infirmières c'est ça que
c'est c'est exigeant c'est un mystique
et exigences et comme tout métier
exigeant ça demande beaucoup
effectivement mais je crois que c'est
quand même hyper stimulant
sauf que plus on va recruter plus mieux
ça va aller mais ça va déjà quand même
très bien au chaud parce que c'est la
deuxième fois que vous faites une
campagne de recrutement comme celle là
l'année dernière je pense que vous avez
fait le même
oui la même activité oui deux fois
c'était bien passé très très bien est-ce
que long terme vous avez vu que vous
avez recruté sont restés oui bayeux pour
plus parvenu à dépasser ses équivalents
le seuil est toujours le même le même
roulement d'un grand alors on peut se
présenter à partir de 8 heures au chum
directement tout à fait pour toute la
journée on arrive à l'heure convenue m'a
effectivement très bien la tâche en
taille à merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous et merci donc de 8 heures à 16
heures oui à 16 ans a très bien au chaud
merci merci